they're opening the big one little bait
box great they got a leash for something
only [ __ ] what kind of a snake is that
bow reticulated python python python
he's really big you like to move around
there's some boots right there man
alright Mike we're back look back what
do you got now man this is it's not
big-ass snake golden child reticulated
python right motley golden child motley
golden child see that one I hit to light
what it look like like a rainbow right
look at that yeah it's amazing sin now
people are always scared of snakes right
mm-hmm think they're slimy they think
they choked you and attack you it's not
the case well at all now this onic is a
top predator where you come from right
come from Asia Indochina now these
snakes are classified as the real man
heaters you know in the world hope sorry
I took my headphones off and the reason
why yeah muffled oh yeah well he's
straight this is a workout 24/7 that's
what I mean when it goes around stuff
don't worry he's cool
I think it'll be all right he's gonna
slither around oh you're good don't
worry don't worry don't worry you're
good I promise we're gonna do this part
from here if it's smaller yeah you guys
so really fast he pursues my mom so he's
a monster right but he's cool bro he
means no harm no I don't live here I
live in Miami right uh-huh so I don't
know this snake he worked with a snake
every day
uh-huh so this is what I explain to
people I work with a lot of animals
especially on my platform and most of
the animals are my first time
interacting with them and everybody sees
these cool experiences but you guys have
been almost brainwashed by the media for
so many years you know yeah oh this this
is evil this is bad this attacks you not
the case at all right you know this is
this they can easily hurt me but he sees
no threaten us at all yeah it's amazing
now this is an apex predator so in a
jungle where he comes from he's the top
dog right you know nothing can take him
out of the wild except for you know a
human yeah or maybe a tiger or something
they come across packs but interesting
sick snake bro
[Music]